oh my god i'm gonna send it to you in high uh definition just wait for my email
it's a comprehensive kinematics kind of performance report you'll see your rhythm
your timing your um tempo does it like judge me no no but yeah they might be able to automate
booty scoring that's cool so is this estimation post algorithm you uh yeah i don't get it
so it's so cool yeah yeah we're doing something similar for sparring i'm sparring um myself so
i've been doing check one for 15 years oh my god yeah um so i i did take one with um
certain people from us us team yeah yeah yeah but yeah maybe yeah i was from the philippines
and yeah so this i know this point yeah that was the sport i know it's amazing i just wish
there's more funding because like there's a lot of times where it's like always self-funded
yeah i know that's like the worst part that's financially dependent but yes like always going
to competition is like fun like meeting new people yeah you know teammates even like just so much fun
oh my gosh yeah was this helpful like the entire thing for you i think it was like
that's a pretty good experience like i've never experienced anything like this yeah like seeing
yourself yeah yeah like i'm not i never judge myself oh of course i judge myself yeah like like
like i tell you yourself yeah no i don't do that stuff yeah yeah this is great yeah we have a lot
of um really good people lined up before for this we're only getting 50 athletes this time
oh yeah
yeah so yeah master jeffrey walk would be here i think at the end of next week
my first mom will be here master artist wait i asked them and they were like i have no idea
what you're talking about oh my gosh you you have yeah yeah i don't know where did you talk to her
because she just signed up yes oh yeah yeah that's like two weeks ago okay yeah yeah yeah yeah oh i
think that's what yeah that's why she was she knows already what i'm talking about when you're
talking last saturday so oh i see i see yeah yeah yeah she already signed up i said i just sent her
the link and she within five minutes she signed up so yeah um yeah that's so it was so nice to meet
you oh my gosh yeah this is crazy um yeah uh do you know your way out um do you know the campus no
but but i'll figure it out i'll deal with it okay um let me know if you get lost i'm still here
right now yeah
it's so nice i think i could just take it out yeah if you don't mind
yeah wait i just pressed like yeah
so the it was new kind of the protocol that we did with you like from the moment you stepped in and
the warm-up and um it's that i wrote it in the comments but i'll just say a little bit it's like